ja es gab ja mal ein kleines mädchen des
jungen frau wurde wir kennen sie noch
alle kreter thunberg easy und die hat
mal gesagt ein want you tube panic also
ich will dass ihre panik gerate das war
der modus wir sollten immer in panik
seien damit der klimawandel sich bewegen
lasse in den herzen handlungen der
bürger und der politiker ich bin
mittlerweile von panik geschüttet
geschüttelt wenn ich durch die deutschen
städte lauf sind berlin ist hamburg
stuttgart ähnliches leider auch mannheim
wo ich herkomme muss ich sagen man sieht
immer mehr müll man sieht immer mehr
verwahrlosung und ich glaube die
verwahrlosung und der müll die kommen
von der verwahrlosung im kopf von der
perspektivlosigkeit gewissermaßen vom
inneren zittern von der inneren
panischen stimmung die man den menschen
macht dass diese eben panisch reagieren
ungeordnet reagieren sich versuchen
einer müllproblematik zu entledigen ohne
müllgebühren zu zahlen und diese panik
mit ihnen sei der bus von weiten teilen
der regierenden klasse geführt wenn herr
scholz zum beispiel sagt unser
bundeskanzler wir wollen uns unter
hagener meint er wir wollen uns unter
haben zum schafott zumindest sagte das
mit solcher leichenbittermiene und der
habig macht offenbar gar nicht mehr
unter einem albtraum szenario hat er
wirklich gesagt also wenn wir den müll
aus den kopf und die traurigkeit und
tristesse aus dem kopf und damit auch
auf den straßen bekommen wollen dann
brauchen wir ein wenig mit zuversicht
und das sage ich auch ihre richtung
weniger untergangs denken ja ich glaube
da muss ich jetzt mal urlaub schulz
beiseite treten
spd freut sich auch im sinne auch ein
habe ja wenn sie sagen nicht dass keine
untergangsstimmung ich weiß nicht in
welchem land sie leben in deutschland in
deutschland nicht in der schweiz
vielleicht regen deutlich so aus denn
hier geht es wirklich um alles und sie
werden den leuten nicht erklären wenn da
schon in manchen kommunen jetzt
diskutiert wird wir können noch den
alten menschen wärme hallen zur
verfügung stellen
das finde ich wirklich sie haben wir
halten menschen sozusagen sie aus ihrer
eigenen wohnung leer will ja und
sozusagen wie zuwanderer behandelt im
eigenen lande dass christina die
verliebtheit in den untergang den nützt
uns nichts also wer sich auf die
wahrheit
habt ihr euch eine apokalyptische
szenarien für die trägt er noch die
apokalypse auch erleben dass gemacht
dabei geht gibt dort durch die welt
durch eine immer schmutziger werden der
welt übrigens und wenn wir diese
botschaften ständig haben sparen panik
kommt wie kommt das denn bei unternehmen
bei kleinen selbständigen bei leuten die
davon leben müssen dass urlaubsgäste
kommen alles wird verschoben einnahmen
werden reduziert die leute haben angst
am leben und wer angst hat am leben und
vor dem leben der wird das leben nicht
meistern eine herr kessler die
unternehmer haben im augenblick eine
verdreifachung ihrer raserei sei nicht
ihre strompreise kritisiere die kommen
in panik ich habe mir auch keiner der
gerne panik verbreitet aber müssen die
wahrheit sagen wir müssen sagen dass da
im augenblick der deutsche mittelstand
fast am ende ist der kann mit diesen
preisen nicht umgehen die stehen
wirklich vor dem ende und wenn das noch
weitergeht dann haben wir wirklich ein
problem deswegen glaube ich ich verstehe
sich schon richtig
panik will auch keiner verbreiten also
müssen sehen dass es ernst ist und das
müsst ihr aber mehr schreiben durch
apokalypse als einer tür hier soll wenn
morgen die welt unterginge und wenn ich
heute noch ein apfelbäumchen pflanzen
diesen geist brauche doch viel eher als
es ist bald alles vorbei ist können wir
noch mal krachen lassen und da bin ich
einfach angst oder und eskapismus die
zügel schießen lassen
es ist immer eine frage der wahrnehmung
und da muss ich sagen als jemand der nun
in fünf monate in der ukraine war
dort sieht man jeden tag sehr viel
schlimmere dinge als das was auf uns
zukommen könnte aber natürlich soll das
nicht bedeuten dass die menschen sich
keine sorgen machen müssen und ist es
immer natürlich eine frage der
wahrnehmung wo man in dem moment gerade
ist und ich glaube dass das natürlich
auch wenn ich mir die vergangenen fünf
monate anschaue also in den ersten
wochen hat die ganze welt auf die
ukraine geschaut da und jetzt
verschwindet das immer mehr aus den
nachrichten und natürlich dass es auch
ganz normal beschäftigen sich die
menschen mit den problemen die sie vor
ort und vor ihrer haustür erleben ich
glaube was gefährlich wäre wenn wir
sagen dass uns nur noch unsere eigenen
probleme interessieren und wir nicht
mehr auf die ukraine schauen
werden gestern einen campingplatz
besitzerin hier sitzen nicht aus berlin
das möchte ich ihnen jetzt also gar
nicht angreifen sondern aus sachsen
anhalt und gesagt die menschen können
ihre miete nicht mehr zahlen und ziehen
auf den campingplatz als erstwohnsitz
ja die situation am wohnungsmarkt das
bitter und natürlich esther berlin
extrembeispiel auch wir haben eine
leerstandsquote von 0,8 prozent man
findet hier kaum wohnraum also man kann
nicht mehr mehr sich seiner
lebenssituation anpassen und selber
umziehen geschweige denn in dieser stadt
zu ziehen ist ein riesen drama und das
heißt natürlich dass man
relativ schnell gerade auch bei
steigenden rohstoffpreisen jetzt noch in
einen größeren engpass reinkommt dem wir
bewältigen müssen mit mit mehr wohnraum
der zu schaffen ist absolut und wir
müssen auch gucken dass wir wieder
vermieten in unserem land bekommen aber
ich fand den appell gut zu sagen wir
müssen mehr german mut haben und müssen
nach nach vorn renndauer und dennoch ist
der status quo der gerade wenn wir über
die frage wohnungsmarkt reden dass wir
natürlich jetzt erstmal ein vielfaches
mehr an herausforderungen haben und wenn
dann und da bin ich bei den denk tabus
dies in krisenzeiten nicht geben darf
wenn dann kommunale
wohnungsbaugesellschaften sagen wir
können sechs euro 50 als miete durchaus
auch zukünftig stabil am markt halten
dafür müssen wir aber nicht nur wohnraum
preisgebunden im bezahlbaren segment
machen sondern müssen auch darüber
nachdenke gebenenfalls eigentumswohnung
zu bauen damit wir eine mischkalkulation
haben und dass dann politisch abgelehnt
wird aus ideologischen gründen ist ein
bisschen wie diese harbeck diskussion um
die frage atomkraftwerke
laufzeitverlängerung dann haben wir ein
problem und dann wird der müll
irgendwann sinnbilder es ist und wir
brauchen einfach leute die sich für das
gemeinwesen zu engagieren weil sie eben
eine gute zukunft zutrauen und da haben
wir glaube ich zu wenig diese
in ihrer freizeit auch mal will herr
kessler es gibt auch diese drei minuten
straßen cleaning so ein trend bei jungen
menschen sie schon das ist in meinem
umfeld weit es geht sauber ist es den
trend kenne ich jetzt noch nicht aber
würde ich natürlich beim screening für
sein umfeld ein wenn etwas bedeutet wenn
man davon ausgeht dass es auch noch eine
gute zukunft hat und den leuten geht
irgendwo die lust an der zukunft das
zutrauen auch ins gemeinwesen komplett
abhanden mal lässt vermögen meisten
schleifen und das ist einfach ganz ganz
schlimm ich weiß im urlaub in
mitteldeutschland und dort haben die
leute auch schon so einen
niedergeschlagenen eindruck gemacht dann
sah ich ein schwimmbad das war wunderbar
wunder beim zustand habe ich gefragt
warum ich das ja so toll sagte ich ja
der macht das was ihm wichtig ist weil
es ihr wichtig da müsste es gar nicht
man macht nicht dienst nach vorschrift
dass es ihm wichtig doch auch in der
freizeit die blumen zu schneiden und zu
gießen er will dass es schön aussieht
und wenn andere kommen das ist auch
schön aussieht ich fordere es nicht eine
große schönheits offensiv es darf auch
durchaus hell bleiben in berlin bei tag
und bei nacht aber ich glaube wir können
aus kriegs- nur raus kommen danke schön
wenn uns unser land etwas bedeutet wenn
eine zukunft zutraut und gebückt und
gedrückt schaffen habe dass ich das auch
an der kommunikation unserer
bundesregierung muss man sich doch
normal ist wie vor alles
gut aber ich rede nicht über den müll
jetzt aber ihr da gerade die frage ist
doch daran hat die leute zu wandern
lassen die mit zumüllen auch ein anderes
zugang haben das muss man doch auch
sehen andere lang ist doch so wenn wenn
ich das sehe in meinem umfeld das ist in
meinem viertel ist das alles klitsche
sauber aber in anderen vierteln ist es
eben anders und bei ihnen wenn keine zu
gewohnheiten im vettel ja ich bewohnern
der elbe relativ gut sortiert da ist das
nicht so aber wenn sie auf der veddel
sind haben sie andere zu stellen das ist
leider darf man aber heute auch nicht
mehr sagen das ist ja schrecklich sie
dürfen alles sagen aber ich sage es
deswegen weil es jetzt einfach sozusagen
billig zu haben die bundesregierung ist
dafür schuld das hat keiner gesagt
ultimaten zu tun ist sich sozusagen an
der verlässlichkeit der deutschen also
ich gebe ihnen recht was sie brauchen
ist wir brauchen aufbruchstimmung genau
aufgeschrieben und dazu müssen wir erst
mal ein paar infos stimmung hat mit
kommunikation zu tun richtigen das ist
doch das problem und da bin ich bei olaf
scholz und sage wo ist olaf scholz es
gibt viele interviews aber nichts bleibt
hängen keine mut machenden setze
natürlich muss man waren und nahmen vor
dem was kommen könnte aber man muss auch
wieder ein bisschen optimismus und
anpackt mentalität hat jetzt gesagt im
interview gesagt er will dafür dass
nicht einsetzen dass die energiepreis
explosion nicht so groß ausfällt also es
darf schon etwas explodieren aber nicht
so viele sein ein tischfeuerwerk dass es
geht um tatkraft ja auch und ich kann
eben ganz spannendes stichwort dienst
nach vorschrift kißler und daher hat ja
ihre partei vor seiner christa länder
vorgeschlagen dass alle jetzt mal
ranklotzen und mehr überstunden machen
und los geht's deutschland sollen wieder
anschauen anschaffen nicht anschaffen
mit den überstunden sagen ich glaube
dass in unserem land richtig viel an
überstunden geleistet wird und dass
jeder der überstunden macht und machen
möchte das auch tut ich finde aber den
appell dahinter also die haltung zu
sagen jetzt packen wir zusammen etwas an
diese diese haltung zu sein jedes jahr
gehen wir gehen nach vorne verstärken
ich glaube dass er das auch damit
gemeint hat als es um das zu übersetzen
genau das was parteien gefordert hat
nicht so dröge wie der wir jetzt gerade
olaf scholz beschrieben hat sondern eher
mehr christian lindner das habe ich so
fertig das habe ich ja
klar bitte die fdp ist in die fdp
verliebt also würden sie das jetzt den
appell von christa länder unterschreiben
dass die leute mehr überstunden machen
sollen das war die frage
wir brauchen dich von sollen reden
ich habe ihnen das ja gerade eingeordnet
wie ich es verstehe
die frage nicht beantworten weil ich das
ist ja auch keine schwäche ich hab ihn
beschrieben wie ich die frage lesen kann
jeder für sich selbst beurteilen also
bleiben wir doch bei den positiven was
für unsere landwirte sich das licht
ausmachen die können überstunden
letztes noch zu ihrer thelen sebas ist
denn ihre konkrete forderung eine
konkrete forderung dass wir eine
vernünftige politik machen die sich eben
nicht in untergangsszenarien erschöpft
sich nicht im moralischen appellen
erschöpft dass wir eine klare benennung
der ziele machen der wege die darin
einzuschlagen sind und das gilt für ganz
deutschland eben am trinken dazu dass
wir eine zielerfüllung überprüfung
machen dass wir schauen nach einer weile
das tat auch wilma buckel haben nein
nein habe sie lange
keine kommission keine konzession steht
aber ich muss sagen ich schätze diese
sanktionen einen haben sie was erreicht
falls nicht müssen wir gegensteuern
haben diese maßnahmen was erreicht falls
nicht und generell ist der staat einfach
viel viel zu reich und die bürger sind
zu arm und das ist leider gottes auch
ein punkt den wir reden sollten